so i am curious if someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
that's actually so funny because i do
get that question of like i know you but
from what what did you do again and then
i'm like okay
what are the top and i say
i like saying atlanta joker and devil
too
that i mean that's good my list is not
as impressive um i actually
i think i
because i started my career here and
because it is so much of my journey i
would actually say youtube and there's
also an abundance of stuff on youtube
after that i would probably say doll
face which is on hulu yeah all good
answers yeah one of the one of the cool
things about uh this film that you guys
are promoting today is that and you
don't think about it but like kids are
gonna watch this and for some kids it's
gonna be their first like caper movie
their first heist movie yeah they will
not see the left turns that are about to
happen
because you know they're not exposed to
it so um can you sort of talk about that
aspect that kids are going to have a
blast with us or in families that's so
interesting i never thought about it
like that before but i guess that's true
i think that's really cool and i i think
what's so special about that is i hope
that it'll inspire kids just think about
things differently because it is so
different i think what i love about this
movie more than anything is is such a
trendsetter you know it is the first in
my opinion the first animated
action-packed heist movie like you said
and so i hope that they just are like oh
this is really unique and different from
anything else i've ever seen and like
i'm allowed to break rules in a good way
of course i i love the idea also which i
i didn't think about if they've never
really seen a heist movie before and so
in some ways the film does follow this
like traditional heist narrative but
for for children
it'll be completely surprising because
they don't have the like ocean's 11
blueprint right and i think that's quite
cool to think about um
i love that idea yeah and i agree i
think it might inspire like oh action
children's movies yeah which is cool
uh i love learning about like the behind
the scenes of the making of a film so
for you guys for this particular project
is there anything that was like out of
the norm anything that might surprise
soon to be fans about the making of it
yeah it took 900 years to make yeah um
give or take
that's what surprised me about it is i
think we worked on it for literally like
three
yeah yeah i've been on this since 2020
2020. i think sam and mark have been
since like 2019 yeah so just the amount
of time it is taken to put this together
i mean i feel like the result is on the
screen and you see that it's a product
that took time to perfect yeah but that
really took me back yeah and i think
also i i love that they
incorporate sort of our movements and
our
idiosyncrasies like the big dancing with
me and wolf um the choreographer for
that scene
took had me send in just a video of me
free dancing to whatever song i wanted
and they're like very clearly movements
in there that i know i did and that
diane is doing and i kind of loved that
i loved the marriage of
her and myself
did you know when you were recording it
that you're like oh [ __ ] i better get
this right
ooh
the dancing
yeah i mean i sent her like five videos
of me just basically doing the same
thing over and over again but yeah i
mean i knew that she was gonna use some
of it so i was like what movement is
reflective of me is potentially
reflective of diane
and yeah i guess i did feel the pressure
a little bit i would yeah yeah you're
dancing you want the fox to be foxy yes
one of the things about animation is
that like they
often characters and stuff change along
the way like sometimes dramatically or
like situations can really change
especially with animation did you guys
go through like so many like really big
revisions or was it pretty much like
what it was when you first signed on
they revised they revised it
from the first version of the script i
read to what it is on screen there were
so many changes which was kind of
nice because i don't know if you agree
when we saw it for the first time i got
the experience of being able to watch it
like a viewer because i was like oh
that's cool i wasn't expecting that i
didn't know that joke was there so
whereas in other projects you kind of
know what it looks like and you were
there when they were shooting it and
there's no real surprises this was
really enjoyable for me and even beyond
sort of like the the big story line you
know you don't actually know how they're
going to be piecing scenes together
because you do the same lines over and
over again in different variations and
you're not doing it with
the person who is technically across
from you and so you're like i wonder
what the intonation what are they going
to choose how are they going to piece
everything together so even on that
level it's it's cool to see um
everything truly coming together in
animation yeah what is it actually like
uh something like this where you spent
years making it what was it actually
like watching it for the first time like
what what surprised you about the
finished film it was really funny yeah
um i
you know i think i went into it being
like all right kids movie but i
genuinely thought it was like
stimulating and engaging and funny and
so i i guess that surprised me i don't
know if it should surprise me but yeah
for me it was i i knew from the
beginning they were saying that this is
gonna be really stylized and it's gonna
look really different and cool and i was
like cool cool cool cool
but it still surpassed my expectations
so much when i saw just how stylized it
was it is
so beautiful and it's so unique and it's
so different and so even though i knew
that was the intention the degree to
which it was awesome still shocked me uh
my last thing uh uh is it sad to be done
with atlanta this is obviously directed
at one of you yes it is sad i was quite
emotional when it was over we all were
everybody like
cried um
but i think because we knew it was
coming to an end we were able to really
like all right let's like
wrap up these
not relationships but like let's be
intentional about how we end this and
like say goodbye to these characters say
goodbye to these people and now i feel
honestly just like
i've let go
it no longer belongs to us now it's the
world's show
even though hero's still editing so i
guess it still belongs to him but um
i see yeah so i just i don't know i feel
this immense like freedom and like all
right we will all cross paths in the
future we already have me and keith
we've done movies together me and brian
have done some stuff together so um
yes
i feel like onward to the next thing
on that note congrats on the movie hope
it's a huge hit for you guys thank you
for giving me your time yes good to see
you steve